since 1973 major league baseball has
honored the memory of roberto clemente
by annually presenting the roberto
clemente award to players who best
exemplify the game of baseball through
sportsmanship community service and
positive contributions to their team
and ladies and gentlemen the 2021
roberto clemente award nominee for your
pittsburgh pirates
is jacob stallings
ladies and gentlemen here with tonight's
gametime first pitch
representing his father
and his family let's hear it again for
luis clemente
thank you luis
the pirates mitch keller fastball a
little bit above average has a nice spin
on it so he can pitch up in the zone a
little bit but his main pitch is that
curveball and he'll go to that when
necessary full count pitch coming to
jonathan india and he swings and lines
one into center field that's a base hit
boy india turned on it and roped it
right back up the middle and he's aboard
to start the ball game and two reds are
aboard with nobody out for nick
castellanos
deep to center reynolds back
wow
you know reynolds i don't know if that
was intentional but it looked like he
kind of pulled off lorenzo cain a little
bit there whether that was to try and
decrock i think he might have done that
castiano's figured okay that's gone
especially the way reynolds is reacting
that's way out of here nope men at the
corners with one out for vato 264 with
30 home runs
and vato grounds it to the right side
this will get the run home fielded by
the second baseman park the play to
first in time to get vatto but it's an
rbi ground out in the red strike first
it's one to nothing as india comes home
from third and the two out situation for
mike mustakis the one-two pitch and
mustache sends a fly ball into left
field sinking quickly long run and
gamble won't get there it's down for a
hit schrock's home from third to make it
two-nothing reds the right-handed rookie
of the reds vladimir gutierrez
yeah vladimir gutierrez is again a wiry
right-handed pitcher runner not going
and it's a bouncing ball in the hole at
second india goes to farmer one back to
first close not in time reynolds beats
it out that'll be a four six fielder's
choice to erase to sugo at second the
1-1 and moran grounds one right into the
shift jonathan india is playing out in
shallow right gloves it and throws out
moran at first the shift works to
perfection there for the reds pirates go
quietly in the first nominee just to
have his name mentioned with the great
roberto clemente really something that
left him quite awestruck here's a liner
over third that is a fair ball it's
going to miss that sidewall and get down
and around the corner that guarantees a
double for jacob stallings leading off
the second
inning fastball and with the infield in
india
looks back stallings to
down
ground ball off the bat of hoy park
right at india he fields fires tovato in
time
and a nice job by gutierrez to work
around the lead-off double from jacob
stallings in a second trying to keep the
reds above board as far as
scoring runs and hitting the ball out of
the ballpark but he's also battling for
the banning title and there's a bullet
back up the middle
well keller just did get out of the way
of that one
single into center field with two outs
swinging a fly ball left field down the
line curling toward foul territory and
gamble slides
and it's in fairground and it's a in
play here comes castianos around third
the throw the tag he's out standing up
he tried to score from first
and he's thrown out to end the inning
satsugo's strengths has been with men in
scoring position he is hitting 467 as a
pirate here's the set in the 2-2 and a
swing and a fly ball hit to deep left
field long run for schrock angling back
on it can't get to it it's over his head
into the wall hayes will score easily
suzuka around second he's trying for
three the relay from left he's in there
it's a triple and a run batted in and
the bucks on the board it's two to one
two two from gutierrez got a swing in
the ground ball fare right up the first
base line tsutsugo will trot home
reynolds around first heading into
second it goes into the corner castianos
just now digs it out reynolds is
standing at third and he will get in
there with a triple standing up give him
a run batted in and the pirates not this
game at two
i'm gonna fly ball that'll get around
it'll be plenty deep for
ryan reynolds
let's score easily and give the pirates
the lead and give moran a sacrifice fly
two gone sutsugo
left-handed batter here's the pitch and
a swing and a liner over short and into
center for a base hit park into score
another run batted in for suzugo and the
pirates lead four to two here's the
pitch to reynolds and he chops it toward
farmer at short he'll field underhand to
india at second that forces out to tugo
and the side is retired but the pirates
tack on one more cashing in on the
leadoff walk in the fourth six innings
two runs i don't have a pretty strong
start yeah a short outing for vladimir
gutierrez as well the pitch
strike three called right on the inside
corner breaking ball locked him up
stallings is down on strikes two gone
there's the set the 2-2 to newman is
swinging a busted bat roller on to the
shortstop farmer gets in front of it
unloads quickly safe that's an infield
hit for kevin newman payoff pitch
runners go swinging a fly ball well hit
left field playable though under it is
shrock he's got it and that's the inning
and now on the pitch it is the
right-hander chad cool yeah chad comes
in his 22nd appearance another five and
six record at 4.72 era the 1-1
ground ball right side through the
infield that's in the right center field
barnhart rounds second he will head on
to third akiyama starts towards second
and he will stop shogo akiyama
snaps a career-long hitless drought at 0
for 18 and puts men at the corners with
nobody out long wait to hold the runner
in the one two swinging a miss he struck
him out took a little bit off of that
one with this curveball right there that
change up possibly well one out men at
the corners for jonathan india the pitch
from cool
fly ball high into the air into left
center field alford is going to have it
barnhart tagging all the way he will
take off he will make it easily to the
plate and it's now a 4-3 ball game
india drives home the run with a
sacrifice fly to the left on the right
he's swinging kyle farmer over three
tonight
farmer
blasted to left gone
kyle farmer ties it at four
with a solo laser out of here to left i
mean he just smoked it and here's wilmar
defoe to pinch it
toward the line and left and oh
[Applause]
overruns it bad enough that he doesn't
make the catch worse that it's fair for
the reds
wow what a break right there again over
ran the ball how fitting would it be on
roberto clemente day not only for the
pirates to win but to win in this
fashion and the pitch swinging the
ground ball to first votto knocks it
down it trickles beside him the throw to
first defoe is coming to the plate give
it his throw default is safer the
pirates win it defo never stopped he
came around third and the reds pitcher
covering the bag at first didn't react
in time and defo helps the pirates walk
it off on roberto clementine
you